icarus was supposed to be a second earth
some kind of paradise brought to you by
the best scientific minds in the
universe
yeah right you know i wonder they caught
an icarus
big planet-sized dream that came
crashing down
they had no idea what they were in for i
wanted
it pure and simple i've done a lot of
crazy
in my timely but icarus that was next
level
if you couldn't find food you died if
you couldn't find oxygen you died
if you couldn't find shelter from the
storms
you died no
she's an engineer xenoengineer she was
sent with the team to terraform the
place so
yeah she was there when it all went down
the other guys they left as soon as they
could but not mo
that wasn't her style she seemed like
money
what the rest of us people died on
icarus all the time you know
you just tried not to think about it
what happened to her was no accident no
way
[Music]
the journey to icarus was brutal it was
four light years from earth
30 trillion miles and two years in long
sleep
i mean talk about jet lag
[Laughter]
we were the first cohort we were the
first wave of
cowboys you know it was it was a whole
new planet was
unreal then reality kicked in
oh they opened up echoes to prospectors
when all the terraforming went
so i signed on as soon as i could
she offered to drop with us she wanted
to show us around like
like was it her apartment or something
well i figured she just wanted to see
how we do on the first draw
it was like going back in time and
seeing the earth a million years ago
the trees the plants the animals they're
from earth i mean the bio team had
adapted them out the terraforming went
but jesus christ it does your head in it
first
outside the zone it was different
people always think that we had a bunch
of advanced tech up there but
we had nothing we spent everything just
trying to get there
we're like cave people and spacesuits
those first few drops
if we needed uh shelter or tools or
something
well we had to make it ourselves i
barely made it back to the dropshipper
live that first time
yeah got better of course i mean motor
mission
she taught me how to build shelters find
oxygen but
the best thing she taught me was you got
to respect that planet
not to fear it she was smart i mean
cocky as hell but look
she'd been part of the terraforming
group right so
she knew the planet inside now i i mean
literally right
she spoke about it all the time you know
i got the first time terraforming
it wasn't gonna work and about finding
the first exotics
i'm just saying doesn't it feel like a
coincidence
that they declared the planet
uninhabitable just when they discovered
the most valuable material in the
universe
weird day hey i ain't complaining i did
okay out of it
it was the exotics that killed the
terraforming
screwed with the enzymes then again they
changed everything i mean without the
exotics they never would have been a
first cohort
because it was all about the exotics you
find them you
sell them back at the station you get
more gear you go back down find more
drop survive and repeat
on icarus um a handful of exotics
would get you a a new suit uh
a radar uh a rifle but on earth
i would buy you anything you wanted
i talked about a mum and a brother all
the time
the kind of life she could give them
thanks to the exotic she had found
she didn't stay because she needed the
money she had made her money
she stayed because she loved it we all
did
it was addictive she was addicted
the second you felt comfortable on the
surface you take your eye off the
mission clock
and that's how people died it happened
all the time oh yeah
people wouldn't miss their window to get
back to this ship and then
there was no way they'd get back to the
station and that was it
never see them again in a day that's for
sure
the drop started off fine none of us had
ever been to that part of the planet
before not even mow
prospecting in unfamiliar areas are sh i
hated it
but there was always more exotics and
undiscovered areas
so none of us knew what to expect
not back then but moe she was like a
moth to a flame i didn't even notice
she'd wandered off
[Music]
if you're asking me if i feel guilty for
what happened to her
i do
we looked for her as long as we could
but you know there's a big storm coming
and you don't hang about for those ever
a bear attack is my guess
the forests were full i mean anything
could have happened
it wasn't an accident mo didn't come
back because she didn't want to come
back
[Music]
she knew she couldn't go home not after
what happened to that planet in the park
she had played in it
look no didn't want to die she
she was right where she wanted to be
how are you guys you got a girlfriend
here bro
um sorry i'm in touch
my bad just want to say that i'm fine
today is my last drop
i wish that maybe if the terror for me
had worked
you could have been here not what people
could have been here
i see you guys
thank you you know
i'll see you guys soon
bye
you